okay mike
and rosie yes mike and rosie uh where'd
you guys go
grow up where are you from originally
missouri
you're both from missouri we're both
from missouri you guys are married
yes we've been married 41 years 41 years
been together
45 years that's great yeah yeah and
you've been uh
so you're swingers right yes yes
and nudists right as we see both yeah
they're separate things
they're separate things that's why i
have to clarify because it's not like
everyone here is a swinger
yeah we're here to paradise lakes resort
here in
in florida and it's uh there's there's
different contingents i guess of
nudists here some are swingers some are
not
absolutely yeah um i'm going to just
speak freely i'm not sure
you know when you ask us something i'm
the most
vociferous of the both of us that's
right um
you know i don't want to but i don't
want to like uh
commandeer the conversation but
you know i'll encourage rosie to speak
up if you that would be a good
thing because i'd like to see how that's
going to go
i don't talk that much this is what
married couples are like sometimes it's
the other way around
yeah how did you first get introduced to
this
lifestyle well
i might as well
when i was a little kid you know five
six years old staying over at grandma
and grandpa's
well my grandpa had in his stack of
national geographic popular mechanics
and stuff like that he had under that
stack was these
nudie magazines they were from they were
naturist
you know black and white blurry pictures
you know well
man i'm looking at this because it's
interesting you know
so i knew about such things
and i mean at five years old me and my
buddy chuckie were going around the
neighborhood asking the neighborhood
girls to pull their pants down you know
that's that's
because that's what we did so
and then growing up there's a place in
missouri called the 40 acre clubs
one of the oldest newness clubs
or campgrounds in in the country so they
would have
there was an ad in the paper about it
you know come to the missouri's oldest
club or the country's oldest club anyway
so when we got together and um
you know we got other stuff out of the
way and we liked camping
i said why don't we try this campground
out in missouri so we went there
in 1983 yeah and just
had a great time we were the youngest
couple there i believe they thought
our parents dropped us off how old were
you
i was uh 28 you were 25 right
which for there was pretty young i mean
you see
younger people now even but back then at
this place
i don't think we're i don't think
i don't think we're like we weren't that
obviously 28-25
isn't that young yeah uh and then they
told us about
well of course we had to join the which
back then was the american sunbathing
association
so we joined that then you we
got ex uh exposed to there's places all
over the country you know so
that's how we wound up coming down to
florida to cypress cove first
and then we're over at cypress cove is
near kissimmee
orlando area and the people there said
we needed to be
here at paradise lake because this was a
younger group
younger group so we first came here in
1988
and uh none of this was here
the rv park was a campground it was just
it was a campground and then
just outside the doors here are
volleyball courts swimming pools none of
that was here dancing
bands yeah now um i don't even think we
went back to the club did we go back to
the original clubhouse
where the previous owner lives now was
it was their clubhouse and
a pool there and everything i think that
was there but it was november it was too
cold to do anything right
right so we just spent one night it does
get cold
yeah sometimes oh yes yeah i mean you're
not naked
in december right well well we
have a hot tub yes all right yeah we are
right
yeah we're on we're almost always naked
really we don't
yeah we live we live here full time oh
you live here full time
yes you're naked probably 90 percent all
the time unless it is a little chilly
we'll put something on but
when you're going to the bank you've got
to put on clothes i don't like it at
walmart
yeah they kind of count on it
and you're do you have kids no no no
kids
no no one to explain this to other than
your well i mean
my family knows that you know we're
nudists
so it's not a big deal what was their
reaction when you first told them
um well they didn't really
well they weren't surprised you know so
i'm the youngest of seven
and um i mean in in our family we
nobody ran around naked i'd never even
seen any of my brothers and sisters
naked before
but um they i guess as i was growing up
they could see you know i was wearing
little skippy bikinis and
stuff so it wasn't a big it wasn't a big
deal even my parents knew
before they died is there a little
exhibitionist quality to
nudism
fine i'd say yeah i mean
i think for us it kind of always was
that anyway
i mean scampi bikinis yeah you were like
you were
you were miss skimpy bikini right out of
the box well i didn't i really didn't
want to wear clothes so i
did the you know the closest thing i
could
yeah it seems to be a very healthy
community here i mean everyone's seen
like
when i pulled up in my car i'm carrying
my bag some beautiful
girl rode behind a bicycle naked and
just said hey how are you yeah
where is this exactly very friendly
there are a lot of friendly people here
very friendly yeah yeah
that's why a lot of a lot of people like
this
paradise lakes because they said this is
one of the
friendliest places that they've been to
you know everybody talks to them and
doesn't they don't feel like strangers
this is my third or
third third time here and each time it's
like i'm
struck by how just pleasant everyone is
the smiles seem genuine the the the
hellos seem
like just really nice yes like
everyone's just very happy to be here
right does does being naked
make the interactions you have with
others more authentic i mean like
because you don't know who the other
person is you don't know if they're
wealthy or poor could be a plumber could
be a could be a
doctor you don't know yeah
well we talk about that stuff all the
time i mean
so we've been doing this for 38 years
um i feel like even from the beginning
people usually when they
take their clothes off a lot of people
are nervous unless they've been doing it
a long time
you know so when you're nervous they
tend to talk more
and they um
they just they're just talking more
because they don't have they don't know
what else to say
so uh for us
i mean the older we get we're we can be
at the pool all day and maybe not talk
to anybody
it just depends um because we're
we live here we're not we're we're not
driven
to the social aspect as much as we were
when we're younger
right right so we're we're happy it's
just like a regular day at the beach for
us
i mean it's just uh if
we'll open up the somebody that seems
interesting not
not that we have an agenda but it it
just
it really depends we don't even really
know but if if we
if we run into somebody right away they
sit down and start asking us
all these questions we kind of
like wait a minute you know what i've
settled down
in the real world yeah yeah just like
anywhere else if i was
if we were at this grocery store and
somebody came up and just started asking
a bunch of questions
uh that wouldn't go over too good it's
kind of and that's kind of like
where we've gotten to with this you know
we give other people a lot of space and
we might
we might i mean it was a couple years
some of the people
like the don and um
the people that work out in the pool in
the morning they
they took a couple years before we
started talking to them now
because we got to know them i mean we're
when we were
uh waiting in the lobby they were coming
out from their workout routine and they
were glad to see us in the ohio what's
going on they didn't know
okay what are they doing sitting in here
because they don't sit in the lobby
but we talked to them and uh but
we we got to know them we know that
they're they don't have an agenda
and we don't have an agenda so now it's
comfortable yeah
is nudism about freedom just being free
to just
not have to not have to wear clothes not
have to do it
we're all like conforming yeah i think
for a lot of people yeah that's right
so too yeah it's not a sexual thing as
much as it's a freedom thing
right i mean there's a lot of nudists
that just want to be
they just want to be nude they don't
want to be swingers they don't
they just rather not have clothes on
them yeah and the swinger
aspect tell me about that that that's a
whole other part of this community
right yeah you guys are married you've
been married a long time yeah yep
and you go to some of the swinger
get-togethers and
yeah we used to i mean we still do
sometimes but
that that had to evolve
you know i mean when we were both
really young when we met um
it's not something i mean some people
might
it took it took a lot it looked the guy
usually drives it
i'm going to say that i mean i hate to
make blanket statements but don't you
think it's a guy that usually
is and when yeah
we would go to parties we thought hey a
bunch of naked people are getting
together we're going to have a few
drinks and stuff well
we didn't really know there was a
swinger
element element and
but we found out right away you know and
well when you've got a wife like that
you're going to get better well
i mean rosie's defenses went up you know
and and
uh things would happen and
we would never argue in front of people
that never happened no but we'd go home
and like okay
she wouldn't like this and she would let
me know about it and
she's uh we had a lot of discussions
about it
and and the the uh evolving took
years to where we're both comfortable
with just about anything
yeah and you'll go to these events and
someone will
get friendly with with rosie and someone
some
lady will get friendly with you and you
just kind of how does it go
yeah well um
i don't know if it's exactly like we're
not spring chickens anymore yeah
20 years ago um we
we i mean we couldn't go anywhere
without
somebody approaching us or whatever
um we might give off a different vibe
now too so
but we
it's not as easy as people think think
people think that oh
we're swingers you just do whatever you
want
but it's complicated yeah and it's
complicated for us because
the to have a mutual attraction for us
it's not
it's not like either one of us goes off
with somebody
and leaves the other one sitting there
playing canasta or whatever
people play by themselves huh i don't
know right i mean
if if we were at a like a convention and
we knew
some people then that's a different
story too
but uh
for us to find somebody that we're both
compatible with and we're both
comfortable with
is just getting harder uh we both try to
keep ourselves in shape we're not
we're not work out themes or nothing
like that but you're very
trying to keep her i say i think he's
drunk
no you're a very attractive couple and i
can see
couples that are younger older
everything you know being attracted to
you guys and
can you can you give some names or you
got a list
you have nice personalities and yeah you
have a sense of humor which is great
yeah
i could see it kind of turning into
something very easy yeah
but but i understand how respect for
your partner has to be
a big part of it right and if it is you
can't just go off and like have fun with
some girl that's cute in the corner yeah
and and leave rosie sitting in the
corner like yeah
it has to be somebody somebody sometimes
has to take one for the team
yeah and it's usually and rosie rosie
gets tired of
taking one for the team you know she
does she's not attracted to guys with
big pot bellies or
you know uh don't take care of herself
she's
her criteria i don't even know how i
match the criteria
but this what you said
hits it right on the head the respect
yeah if you
run into somebody and and the guy has no
respect for his
uh his uh wife or girlfriend whatever
and he's and you can you can tell that
almost right away
because they don't care they don't care
what's going on with their what they're
not paying any attention
it's all about what they want to do and
uh
that relationship probably isn't going
to last no but they do
but they do care um
get more attention we've seen that
plenty of times where
it's got to be it's got to lead to
something yeah because sometimes like
mike said most of the time it's the
it's the guy that's it's his idea most
of the time
but then when he finds out that his wife
girlfriend or whatever
um is getting more attention then he
sometimes he puts the brakes on because
you know that's not exactly what he had
in mind i can imagine this swinging is
not as easy as it sounds
it is not as easy it isn't like i said
it's complicated and we know
so many couples yeah that aren't couples
anymore
right because they didn't have
any boundaries for themselves and
and that relationship probably wasn't
going to last anyway but
it it it kind of fast forwards that
the end of a relationship it's not a
relationship builder
it it can be for us i think we are
together
now because we were able to
overcome the aspects of it that would
drive us apart
uh i mean i feel sorry for anybody that
has sex with one person
for their whole life how boring that
would be yeah
right yeah so yeah
it i think it sure it served us
in in a way to keep us together but now
it's
not because
after a night of of some fun with with
other
couples i would imagine that you've
probably come back to rosie at the end
of the evening and
it really you you need to treat her
really really nicely
and like likewise with you right with
mine
well i mean you can't just be like wow
that was really great can't wait to do
that again you need to show
some well i don't know for us if that's
that's necessary no because it's just a
thing you know it's just
yeah we it doesn't mean the uh
no i get i know i know what you're
talking about but for us that never was
really the case we didn't have to pamper
each other afterwards no it goes back to
the respect thing
right i wouldn't want my partner to feel
hurt or slighted or disrespect it or or
anything negative
yeah that that kind of function but it
doesn't i mean swinging is not my thing
but
i can imagine if i did it yeah i would
be more concerned about how my partner
felt than
yeah but it has been my new partner but
it does enhance your relationship
you know how do you feel when you see
a couple who
are like hugging and kissing and holding
hands at the pool
because they're over compensating
yeah one or both of them is might
see somebody else or they know they
might be doing something with somebody
else
and then they're we call it lovey-dovey
you know
we go okay there's insecurity there
i mean when yeah and then later you see
maybe not so lovey-dovey you know if
we're walking around holding hands and
smooching and like
calling smooching that's what you do in
grade school
that would be a problem i mean that it
just seems so funny
do you think do you think people are
just not meant to be monogamous their
whole lives
[Music]
uh well some people
i don't think they have a choice but
yeah i think
i think uh nature
[Music]
alone makes would
would i i don't know your upbringing too
yeah i mean but i don't even know if
that helps because you can have the
strictest upbringing and still
i think it's just how you grow up and if
you're thinking for yourself
i think that's the key right there if
you're thinking for yourself
and not just doing what was ingrained
upon you right yeah if you if you
weren't a creative or
free thinking person yeah and you only
did what your parents
told you to do right you'd be married
with six kids
i probably would be but unfortunately
for her she met me so
yeah but you guys are happy your
marriage has been
yeah it seems like it's still great yeah
yeah we
i mean i this is why we we stay home a
lot
okay why should we were going to go out
the last two nights well
well it rained a little bit so we can
find all kind of excuses not to go out
yeah
and we have fun at home the the pandemic
because it plays into this too
really didn't affect us that much
because we're happy at home
we have a little dog that we're we both
love this little dog
and she's part of our lives so
when when we can actually sit here and
say okay the little dog is more fun
being home with the little dog than
going to a swinger's party yeah
you can tell okay we've been we've been
around a little bit
yeah cause okay that was fun everything
but it's not like sitting
around with our little dog watching tv
it sounds boring yeah
it's like companionship ends up being
what's most important
i mean we're together 24 hours a day i
mean we are
always together like today he actually
went out by itself for maybe 30 minutes
but that's it did you did you time yet
no no but i'm just saying
you know if we didn't like each other
that much we would
yeah we're together all the time and we
don't have any problem with it we
we laugh and joke i mean people if they
watched us at home
they would think we're out of our minds
we're like
making up jokes and laughing yeah and
stuff you know and it's very
well it's it's fun you know you
you rosie people don't really know how
outgoing rosie is and how her sense of
humor and everything because she's
you seeming well you're intimidated a
little bit when you get out in public
and everything but around me
you don't seem to have much of a problem
now but you feel like this lifestyle
nudism and
the swinging is has helped your
relationship
yeah absolutely i would say so yeah um
because you know years when we first
did get into the swinging mike says well
we can either do this together or
somebody's going to do it behind
somebody's back and that's not good for
a relationship
doing you know cheating on your
significant other
we have a friend that said uh we won't
say their name but this cut this young
couple
he's actually says in front of the girl
he's about to marry he says
i'm a cheater not a swinger and she's
this girl looks at him
and we're thinking to ourselves you are
an idiot yeah but it was
it's true and it probably still is true
today and they aren't swingers
no they're not but i mean they're
they'll get naked and stuff like that
but
uh but there are still swimming people
like that that are cheaters
yeah because there's couples that we
have known that
they would only swing with just one
other couple
that's it well then then you know
they started cheating behind the other
one's back without telling them they
were going out to meet the other person
you know so it's like
what's the point i imagine there are
very different many many different forms
of swinging right yes
someone uh just recently who a couple
days ago who
she and her husband like to be watched
yeah they don't really
engage in sex with other couples as much
as they just like right
be watched at these parties exactly and
they get a crowd because they're both
attractive and they
yeah they get off on that yeah
how many how many couples like got upset
when
when we wouldn't be exclusive with them
a lot
well i want to do that there's no
there's a fine line between just having
sex with
one woman and only two you know so like
it's not like you're trying to rack up
numbers but it wasn't about building
another
same relationship you you have with your
own
spouse but but you're right you have
lawyers uh
a lot of a lot of couples the guy
doesn't even want to be involved he
wants to
watch his wife have sex with other men
uh
i don't think we run into many women
that want to do that no
that uh that we we've ever met i'm sure
they're right
believe me if it's out there it's out
there
job yeah what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in all
your years of this lifestyle
about about human nature about people
about yourself
[Music]
anything well yeah what do you think i'm
not really sure
what i what that we don't learn anything
no
i'm not really sure what my answer is to
that um
[Music]
i learned that you know even if mike is
attracted to
another woman uh that's it it's just
attraction he's not gonna go off with
her you know so i
that i learned yeah there's i mean you
trust him
yes he's coming home to you that's right
yeah see
when we first started i was you didn't
know i was jealous
you know cause you know we were not
really into our relationship
long enough for me not to be but i was
17 when i met him you know so
whoa whoa
it was uh
so that that that i did learn
yeah what i just
what i kind of learned is uh it
it can be just a normal thing i mean
um i mean i'm not going to go rosie and
i aren't going to walk in a walmart and
like screw in the produce aisle but
but we we could very easily walk in
there naked
and not think anything of it we wouldn't
feel like
this is weird i mean people have dreams
about in their nightmares i guess
they're
they have dreams about being naked out
in public right
we don't have dreams like that because
it's not a big deal right
uh i mean right we're right real
comfortable with that
there's so many people we've met that
come to the nudist
resorts and they'll say oh i had to get
a lot of drinks with me before i would
take my clothes off and that's
you just said it this morning what about
the people that are laying in a lounge
or
naked by the pool and got to put a wrap
on to get up and go
like into the restroom or go get a drink
or something that have been nudists
for most of their lives but that's what
they do they have to put something on
to go from the lounge chair to the
bathroom or
but that's well but that's that's what
they want to do
we think that's strange but who are we
to say what's strange
right so but everybody has their thing
so it doesn't really matter if they're
swingers or their nudists or whatever
the people just
have their own personalities and i guess
the best thing
is let them have them
you know if you're gonna if you're gonna
learn anything it's like let people do
what they want and
certainly
[Music]
the the thing that's bothering i would
say bothering me the most that we never
saw before in in the 38 years of doing
this
we never saw before
i'm going to be very careful about what
i say here
we never saw people coming into a place
sporting their political attire
promoting an agenda that's totally
outside of swinging our nudism or
anything like that
they they it seems like they have to
force their
uh political agenda on other people
and we've uh
it was a few years ago we asked the
management here at paradise lakes
would you please put up a sign on the
door that says
leave your political attire at home
and they did and and you could i think
they still have one down in the
on the door downstairs but not every
place is like that
i mean the the management at the time
and i think the current the
current owners obviously agree with that
concept because they they keep they they
have the
notice on the door why divide
people when we're all supposed to be uh
at least we're all
pretty much agreeable to be nudists and
everything
why slice it up any more than that yeah
you know
uh it just doesn't make any sense to me
but people but people are like that
people want to okay we have let's get a
group let's have a group you know
we we i'm like groucho marx i don't want
to be part of a
what is it i don't want to be a member
of a club that would have me as a member
or whatever something like that
people love to hate yes they do and it's
human nature unfortunately
that's how it is right now but um you
would think okay well here we are in
this environment
we can get past that but no given
everything being equal people are still
going to want to segregate themselves
from somebody else and if and if it's
not
obvious they'll find somebody to do it
with so
so that's another reason why we're we we
just
sit i mean we'll sit by ourselves and
we'll
take things in until we see how the lay
of the land is yeah
we're we're not part pressured
because we don't want to go down that
road because how many times we've been
at the pool
hey how you talking you know oh you have
a boat well we have a boat well that's
nice
we'll talk about that well then next you
know something else comes up i'm like
why are we why is that why is that
important
yeah so instead of being disappointed
we just uh you know we
just stay to ourselves right it's it's
it happens in the news community that's
right yeah we're the most
anti-social social people you're ever
going to meet yeah
yeah all right mike and rosie thank you
so much for sharing your story
thank you i wish you guys the best of
luck having fun this weekend thank you
thank you
thank you very much
that was fun
you